Simeon spots mafia 3 review and progress
is up on the site now the full review
will be up shortly and I'm gonna be
sitting down now with Scott Butterworth
who wrote the full review along with
Jake Decker who spent some time with
mafia 3
thanks so much we're going to meet guys
of course I definitely didn't write a
review but I played a good a good amount
of it I'd say well cutting there he is
he's gonna have to like sift through
hours and hours of footage it's gonna be
really fun for him and you well you sat
through a lot of the game pretty much
your entire weekend we got yeah we got
game code basically when the game came
out and you spend your entire weekend
play yep that is completely accurate I
did nothing with play mafia this weekend
what you mean hey there were there way
worse things you could spend your
weekend doing than just like playing
video games you know hard to hard to
complain but yeah like I said it is a
very long game it took me roughly 40
hours get through the campaign I've now
beaten it and done a fair amount of the
side content all that kind of stuff and
in total it took me a little more than
40 hours but suppose I feel like that
game could have benefited from some
editing like it would have been a much
stronger experience at 20 or 25 hours if
for no other reason than the fact that a
lot of the missions grow fairly
repetitive I mean it at a certain point
the game falls into a very clear pattern
that makes a lot of sense in the context
of the narrative in the world but still
ends up forcing you to repeat the same
kind of actions over and over and over
again both to kick it off there were
some things that you did really enjoy
about the game and some stuff that it
did really well what yeah I think you
said storytelling in particular was
really strong yeah I mean I highlighted
that in the review in progress and it
remained true to the end to like the
story is excellent I mean every every
aspect of the writing is astoundingly
good full II stand by everything I said
in the review in progress about all the
hope I expressed about how the narrative
my play out it really does I mean the
plot is a relatively straightforward
revenge tale so it kind of hits all the
beats you expect it well revenge tale
but it does culminate in this like
Shakespearean ending and and all of that
is is so meaningful mainly because you
really get to know the characters over
the course of the game there's so much
attention paid to fleshing out
everyone's perspectives and their
motivations and their backgrounds and
everybody has so much nuance even sort
of the side characters like the
inconsequential mission givers are given
just enough kind of flavor that you get
a sense of even why they're helping
Lincoln
the protagonist through this like his
rise in power and his quest for a
revenge like all of that is is done so
well and actually I have two especially
highlight the way that the narrative is
framed because it's super clever it
intercuts like cutscenes from 1968 when
the game is set modern-day documentaries
about the events of 1968 and Atkins from
a congressional hearing that occurs
somewhere in between and using all three
of those to flesh out the story is
pretty ingenious like it gives you such
a well-rounded view of the events and
allows them to kind of like vary the
ways in which they're conveying story
and it works I mean start to finish the
game's story wise at least is super
compelling and super interesting I was
invested the entire time yeah how did
you feel about that that opening segment
for you Jake well I mean I I'm with him
I love the documentary style that
they're doing with that and it's weird
that we haven't seen anything like that
before
right it's make sense yeah like and it
fits so well with the setting and
everything like that and the music is
really good soundtrack music is really
good like I have trouble getting past
the the menu screen because it starts
out with all along the watchtower and I
just let it run for a couple minutes
yeah and there's like the doors and Sam
cook and yeah it's just yeah endless
like I feel like just about anybody
regardless generation will connect with
the music because one because it's good
but two because it is like the most
iconic music start to finish from that
decade and it was a great decade for
music so yeah that's that's saying a lot
so we have some questions in the chat
with people talking a lot in the chat
particularly about the games glitches of
course if you have if you're listening
and you have any questions for the
reviewer please go ahead and throw those
out there but I don't think we can talk
about mafia without talking about the
glitches because they've been some
amazing crazy glitches that even happen
in our streams yes
yeah the flying boat the infamous flying
boat from the Mafia live stream from
last week which is still on the site go
check it out it's sad and hilarious
yeah unfortunately so I played through
on Xbox one and actually right now I'm
playing on ps4 and Jake's gonna be help
me out and play some PC so that we can
kind of gauge exactly how these issues
affect the different platforms but at
least on xbox one I experienced a lot a
lot of problems like a and a range of
problems as well I mean I
handful of hard crashes and me probably
six seven eight hard crash is just like
instantly back to the dashboard with no
like warning or explanation just oh the
application close by and then so that
was the worst of it but there's also
stuff like yeah like boats flying off to
the distance or an enemy spotting me
through a wall when I'm like you know in
cover against a wall and they clearly
shouldn't be able to see me but somehow
they they know and they're alerted to
like mission objectives that are just
broken like I'm told to go go here and
hijack this boat and I get there and
there's just there's no boat like the
mission marker where the boat should be
is there but there's no boat you know
that there were there was more than one
instance of something like that so
there's this huge range of technical
problems um and that's all in addition
to the fact that the game is just not
super great-looking I mean I'm by no
means you know commit like I don't care
if a game isn't the most you know
picturesque graphically beautiful game
in existence like you know a decent
looking game great that's good enough
for me but it's almost like distracting
it points in no I feel like there's a
lot of pop in as you're driving there
are blurry textures throughout just just
all kinds of strange so odd lighting
some some really weird instances of like
lighting like flickering or inexplicable
shadows just so many just weird things
that I'm not used to seeing it in like a
big triple-a release like this Jake I
know you didn't spend as much time with
it but did you notice all of these
visual issues on PC it hasn't crashed
for me yet I think I played about four
or five hours hasn't crashed there
hasn't been many like big glitches that
have ruined the experience I think now
that you mention it though there was one
objective where it never pointed me to
where I was supposed to go so I was just
wandering around with the time going
down and then the time it done I lost
and then I restarted and then it was huh
but apart from that like it's been
running pretty smoothly especially once
that day one patch kicked in yeah cuz
for PC originally like the framerate
wasn't that good but yeah they unlocked
it over the weekend with a relatively
big patch from what I understand
although and I I beat the game on xbox
and I mean this is part of why we're
testing the multiple platforms because
we are hearing different experiences
from different people on different
platforms so in the interest of
thoroughness we are like playing through
as much as we can on all platforms to
make sure that we're giving an accurate
assessment of how these sort of glitches
and technical flaws affect the different
skews of the game yeah I the oh also the
visuals too like I mean
I am playing on PC so it's bound to look
at least a little bit better but I
haven't I don't think I've had as much
of an issue with poor graphics I guess I
mean it looks pretty nice to me for the
most part on PC yeah but there are some
like I don't know like some things will
look great and other things will look
really bad yeah even on console that's
true as well there's certain things like
oh you're like cutscenes will look
really good or certain like character
models look and then you'll get like a
car and it's a why's the so low res
right like it's it's jarring that you
have this mix of things that look great
in things that really don't and even
beyond the the graphical glitches I
think Scott one thing that you brought
up is it's kind of a particular problem
with the game is that it's repetitive
that it feels that despite that great
story you're doing the same things over
and over again yeah unfortunately that
is very true and there are some really
memorable moments within that like every
now and then you get a mission that's
super memorable and is a little more
interesting will be like you know a car
chase or a boxing match or something
that is you know distinct in its
gameplay and and memorable in the way
that it impacts the story but between
those missions is a lot of filler and a
lot of repetitive stuff like I said so
within the structure of the world
basically
Lincoln is trying to dismantle the
Italian mobs hold on new Bordeaux which
is their New Orleans inspired setting
and so he does that by taking over one
district at a time and each district
plays out the exact same way you start
by interrogating somebody and killing
enforcers then you go steal some stuff
and maybe break some stuff and then
eventually you've done enough that you
can take on the boss like that like the
low-level boss and then once you take
him out you repeat that execs the exact
same process to get at the higher-level
boss in that same district and it's the
same across the entire I mean after the
opening like six or seven hours once
you've recruited your team it falls into
this pattern that just repeats for the
rest of the game and the weapons in
combat as well aren't really varied
enough they're they really aren't I mean
it's extremely standard generic
open-world shooter gameplay it does very
little to distinguish itself from other
games within that same space I mean it
plays like in terms of the gameplay if
you like this game could have come out
five years ago I mean there are really
no new ideas and even the old ideas
aren't necessarily executed super well I
mean moving between objects and cover
doesn't it just feels kind of clumsy
there's very little weapon variety the
AI is like noticeably bad
every now and then they lose something
intelligent to surprise me but for the
most part they are incredibly
predictable which makes a lot of the
gameplay really boring I just had a
pretty good time playing through like a
stealthily if for no other reason than
you start out with your ammo capacity is
like non-existent and it's just easier
to save bullets and it can be kind of
fun like sneaking up on people because
some of the the death animations are
really satisfying things like that but
yeah the moment-to-moment shooting and
even the driving is just kind of bland
and expected and underwhelming what
about side content I I assume with an
open world there's gonna be a lot of
different things to explore and do you
would assume that wouldn't you um yeah
there's not a lot there's a lot to see
in new Berto it is a very fully realized
world and it feels very live and it's
actually pretty detailed and there's so
many different districts you can go to
however there's not that much to do in
the game and to be honest I don't miss
not being able to go bowling with my
cousin but every now and then you kind
of want to just like screw around and
just like explore the world and shoot
people and do whatever you want to do
and just kind of take a break and have
fun and Mafia doesn't really support
that I mean if like there aren't really
side missions beyond like doing favors
for your mission givers and they're
always the same kind of favors and so
there's no real side content beyond that
even if you just want to like screw
around and wreak havoc there's no really
great way to do that because you can't
save like all saves are Auto so you
can't like save the game blow everything
up and go okay that was fun and revert
back to where you were like there will
be consequences if you just go around
shooting people for fun so you almost
kind of can and then in addition to all
that there's no fast travel system which
is crazy for no one game and it's a big
it's a big map so I actually spent I I
was sort of joking with someone that I
spent most of the game watching
cutscenes and commuting because you just
you just commute from objectively more
than once I was forced to drive across
the map to watch a cutscene and then
drive directly back to where I just was
to act on the information that I got
which is crazy that makes sense in the
context of the story that okay you need
to talk to this person who's located at
this place she's okay so it makes sense
but just from a player perspective it's
not fun to spend five minutes commuting
somewhere and then five minutes
commuting directly back there's no
reason for that alright so we'll
probably have the full review up on site
either today maybe tomorrow because we
want to check out the other versions
make sure that these glitches carry
across all yeah like that's that's
what's holding us up right now like
review is written we're just kind of
testing things and making sure that
we're comfortable putting that forth is
the final review all right but for Mafia
3 if you want more impressions if you
want to read our full review in progress
or if you're watching this later and you
want to watch the full review we'll have
that up on site soon and if you have any
questions for Scott Butterworth hit him
up on Twitter and butter whomp yup